[Music]
hey guys tyler with lock labs here today
we are using the auto propeller gt turbo
and we're going to be programming a key
for this 2018 jeep wrangler
i
have the glove box dropped as you can
see there's a start connector back here
which i'm plugged into
you also have to since i'm using the
turbo power the vci so i have a
battery clamp cables that
run
to the 12 volt so we can power our vci
so we can communicate
so we're plugged into the star connector
we're going to come over to our tablet
we're going to go to immobilization
we're going to hit agree
we're going to go to chrysler usa
and this vehicle is not going to auto id
so we're just going to go select by
system
proximity phobic rfh
we're going to scroll down and you can
see this option that says type 12
wrangler 2018 and newer so we're going
to go ahead select that option
and right here it's just telling us that
we have to use the star cable which we
are
and we're gonna hit okay
[Music]
so now we're gonna go ahead check number
of keys
two keys in the system we're gonna read
the security code
which is one two one eight nine
and we're going to hit add smart key
so it says turn on the hazards
and make sure the ignition's off
ignition's off i went ahead and turned
on the hazards we're gonna hit okay
one two one a nine that's our security
code
place the key near the start button and
press the
press and hold the start button with the
key so we're just going to take the tip
the key and press and hold the start
button with the key
and it says program success
hit okay check number of keys
and it is three so we're gonna come
around
lock and unlock is working
we're gonna go ahead and try to crank
the car
press the start button fire starts right
up that's all there is to it thanks guys
[Music]
you